work and we all
take this a step further drawing on
nomics and social psychology to create
deadly effect people faces positive ways
over the last five years Nick's team has
launched a string of creative behavior
change products and tools including the
i am not a plastic a shopper teacher
ready to text children's books and
digital tools internet buttons and
history 10 which is the project we
discussed today nicola been included in
britain radical list in 2012 and his
team is when a number of wood for the
projects including a webby in lieutenant
2012 met the best non-profit project
mystery man thank you thank you very
much thank you hi everybody first of all
I apologies for this lightly rushed late
beginning the subway system despite an
air conditioning let me down today so I
gotta be stuck but it's really nice to
be here thank you so much new
invitations for setting it all up i I've
got a kind of 10-day trip in my favorite
city in the world going around talking
to lots of interesting people and really
glad to be here this morning so I'm
going to talk a bit about the route and
origins of history pin and then it gives
you a little bit of a demo of how each
bit of the kind of project works as it
stands and how the kind of the world of
history pin fits together and then talk
a bit about what we're going to be doing
over the next 12 months and how the
projects developed in its kind of core
purpose and and and the function that
the community is really defined for it
and so as robbie says the the
organization behind history pin which I
run is called we are what we dopes sorry
hold on a minute is there cool we aren't
we do as a not proper behavior huge
company I willing to be very much about
we all we do but it to give you the kind
of the the rationale for history pin we
work as an organization on a series of
different social and environmental
issues those issues are always things
that are very damaging for for quality
of life very expensive for the
government to to deal with and very
consequential for communities and for
society as a whole and
our second I'm kind of reason for being
around these issues is that they are all
things that are defined by and sustained
by people's everyday behaviors so these
are some of the issues that we're
looking at at the moment food waste
obesity and the issue that kind of we
worked hard on understanding better when
we put in history pin together with the
inter generational divide so we did
around 18 months worth of research and
development around the nature and extent
of the gap between older and younger
people so lots of people might create
history pin from a kind of cultural
heritage perspective it could have come
into being from an academic perspective
it could have come in from institutional
and kind of access to collections
perspective and it does do all of these
things but for us the motivations were
that it was a behavior change tool to
bring older and younger generations
together in compelling mutually
interesting ways the starting point
being that that gap is bigger and more
damaging the new server beam and the
traditional approach to intergeneration
ality tends to be that kind of awkward
high school disco a project with the
seniors in one corner of the young
people the corner and you have to go
pick your senior and have an awkward
conversation every company and when
actually the the exchange of culture and
history and identity and values across
generation is extraordinarily valuable
for society and for those individuals
it's just two separate worlds of kind of
developed within modern society and and
something like the stories behind and
the narrative and the memory behind old
images and videos and audio clips are a
powerful mutually compelling way of
bringing generations together and so
alongside that work we were doing as an
organization there's also some things
that happen in my life which kind of
started to develop some of the ideas
around history pin and this is my gran
on the right hand side here and my
great-aunt I Jenny and this is August 14
1943 in a little village in
leicestershire when they were working
his land girls and before my gran died a
few years ago we spent a lot of time
together around old photos and stories
and it's quite a bumming quite a big
farming family and my granddad died
before I was born so I was quite
matriarchal and the relationship of my
gran was always quite kind of
formal perhaps but our time together
around these photographs completely
transformed their relationship and
obviously maybe which I've done it a lot
sooner and a lot more often but
essentially it brought home to me in a
way they hadn't been before the power of
coming together around cultural heritage
materials to share stories and compare
lives and to show that the difference
between all newer generations is not all
that it necessarily made out to be and
this vote in particular she loved
because just after it was taken and for
American GIs drove down the road behind
this field and was so there I was so
caught by my grands probably very short
skirt for 1940s that they crashed into
the ditch and and they had to be looked
after by my gran and her family she was
working for over the next few weeks so
she really liked the idea that she was
kind of eye catching Lee prissy in a hay
day and told the story a lot in her
final days and so this didn't obviously
one route for that from that story is
kind of genealogical and that whatever
that kind of sphere is well catered for
and they're obviously you know if I'd
wanted to create a family tree out of
all of this then I could have gone to 10
places to do it but I it didn't actually
lead me towards the genealogical process
it led me to want to find out much more
about this time in this place what the
what the context was what world she
lived in and that's not really what
genealogy can I lead you toward and so
what I did next was to go out into the
into the village and to have lots and
lots of conversations with people about
particularly about the 1930s and 1940s
but but more broadly as well and to try
and create a little map of like as it
was in the 30s and 40s in that
particular village and and this is a
little this is a smattering of some of
the contents collected hundreds of
conversations and people and most of the
conversations so those conversations
generated a bit of content and a story
and also developed a relationship so
without kind of really realizing it I
was doing two things I was creating a
local archive for the village which
happens all over the world people go
through this process a lot and I was
also generating
links and connections and fostering
social capital within that community and
I managed to find a whole load of really
interesting things this was the road
that those gos drove down this was just
before the war when it was a road that
could still be walked on and and parked
on you can't see it very well in this
life but that's the hunt and if you know
about the hunt but basically we're not
allowed to do anymore and which is a
good thing which is a good thing but
with posh people on horses chasing
around foxes and then setting that dogs
on them but they this is what they were
doing in the early 1930s on this road
ten years before this in the very early
1930s a lady sitting next to that road
which I heard lots of interesting
stories about people used to do along
that road and a couple in the village
that ran a hotel which no longer exists
and then finding out you know the kind
of the rooms within that hotel in the
stories and the kind of things that went
on and just kind of uncovering bit by
bit the story of this particular bit of
the world at this particular time even
managed to find some old video footage
from the early 1960s of people driving
down this road at one of the earliest
kind of bits of camcorder footage and
hardly any cars on it so so what all of
this as I said did was start to show the
local power of this communal
storytelling and memory gabbing
experience it was a really lovely thing
to do with that community and he got I
got to know them very well they got to
know me and they got to know each other
better we're at a time now when we don't
really know our neighbors and so
alongside the inter generational gap we
were also looking at the way that people
could come together with people who they
live near which is a kind of
increasingly and oddly rare these days
and so we then put together the research
we've been doing on intergeneration
ality put together the experiences that
I had had and we had had and start to
develop some ideas for how there was an
activity which communities could do
together which happens
you know radically and occasionally in
different communities around the world
but essentially how could we make it a
ubiquitous activity how could we kind of
behalf make this activity easier to do
and make it more relevant and more
mainstream aggregated into something
bigger join it up and make connections
between all of this work and make it a
little bit more permanent and it's
self-perpetuating so we had and it's
really important in all of our work to
recognize that there are lots of
behaviors that we want to kind of
inculcate within the mainstream but they
are when we start they're normally
associated with a particular group of
people so in the environment a perfect
example of that in any community there's
a kind of eco-warrior people and that
tends to infect those behaviors to make
them not particularly relevant for the
further for the wider community and
particularly in you know within
mainstream culture lots of those things
we do are doing good and doing green are
things that the one percent club do and
with it with around something about
local archiving this kind of activity
and coming together around photos and
talking about you know times of the war
is something that that is not appealing
to young people as a kind of intuitive
day to day activity so that was our main
challenge and we recognize that as I
made change to begin with and we had we
designed something from the very top
called the 16 year old boy test and the
idealistic senior boy test was it he was
thick and I'll throw it up in the wall
in front of a classroom 16 year old boys
and they would shrug their shoulders and
want to do something else but if you
started injecting technology and
creativity and communications into this
content and made it feel more relevant
and exciting then you could therefore
kind of create new associations with the
behaviors around that content it would
drive them to go out and find it and
talk to their grandparents about so we
tried two concepts one was the first
idea which was to do with scale and to
do with replicability and obviously that
16 year old boy test was that the map
didn't actually look like this the mat
looked like this which was you know for
every every location there was also a
date so this idea of forth by mentally
mapping started to emerge with you
you would even split a map into a whole
series of temporal layers this is each
layer is just a decade here but
obviously as the archive got denser it
could be split up again and again and
again and and so that was the first
content we explore which also shows how
you could gather thousands and thousands
and thousands a piece of content in one
location because you could just carry on
splitting it via those those those
layers of time and allow people to
explore particular dates in particular
locations and what list did was we had a
concept early on which we were kind of
fascinated by about the idea of every
spot on the planet having this vast
column of history extending from well
beneath it all in front of it all over
you see time and and and the idea of
being able to go to that spot and then
immerse yourself within those layers I'm
kind of fascinated us in this concept of
4th unnatural mapping mmm I mean that we
can kind of we can sell that idea to
more people so that was one one part of
the big part of the approach the other
part was this idea of overlaying old
images onto their modern backdrops which
immediately injects load of life and
relevance into the content and lots of
people have been doing it really nicely
when we first started testing it there
was one guy in particular called jason
powell who was holding up old photos in
front of backdrops which has now been
kind of famously taken up by by the guy
doing dear photograph and there's lots
of other really nice projects where
people hold up old photographs over old
backgrounds and and essentially what
this did when it came to something like
the 16 year old boy test was take a
piece of content that wasn't relevant an
overlay tanto quanto piece of content
that was relevant and show that the two
had a relationship and it suddenly
injected loads of life and relevant for
food for these of these younger
audiences and and it was a really
compelling way yeah you wouldn't be able
to do that now it was a really
compelling way of getting injecting lots
of kind of creativity and relevance into
cultural heritage content so as one of
the technical and creative element we
also put together a set of very strong
social objectives
the project nonprofit we we will never
commercialize the project in a kind of
traditional sense that lovely paywalls
they'll never be advertising and because
in what the first point is particularly
important to us the widest possible
access to the expiration enjoyment of
historical content a broad aim of the
project that we believed that by
allowing people to interact with content
in these ways and add to it and
contribute and then it could do all the
things we wanted it to around around
behavior change secondly to generate
multiple social capital and
neighborhoods as I describe that process
of coming together around a collective
local memory is a powerful one and
generates lots of those associations and
and and local trust networks Boston is
the same positive intergenerational
context in understanding obviously that
was a very early one provided effective
teaching learning research tools and
opportunities that studying kind of nine
months into the project that's really
starting to to come through that use of
the of the tool within within schools
and within academic settings which we'll
talk more about the end I'm sure and
then finally revision and care of
support for older people that one seems
it was important to us to have that one
in from the beginning because we wanted
to play a big role in what is becoming a
defining issue for our societies
particularly the UK and the u.s. ball
over the world which is the aging of the
population and the the the the
incredible increase in dementia rates
and the clever use of things like
reminiscence therapy and memory phenix
and the role that we could play with in
that setting in the UK for example there
are eighteen thousand care homes I
residential homes whatever the
equivalent here is and that number will
need to double within within 30 years
and so so it's yeah it's something that
we are I'm kind of a long side youth
obesity it's its term is the most amost
expensive parts of DHS budget and I
should imagine here too extraordinary
costs as well so and we put together our
kind of our poor social objectives and
and there they definitely remain at the
Heartland project and always will do and
then we with with all the testing we've
been doing with the results of the 16
year old boy tests
we put together our digital tools which
we be to test it between mid-2010 am in
2011 and launched just over the park in
the museum city of New York in July last
year and the yeah we've had during that
time I mean I'll come back to some of
the challenges of the project but the
site as I was kind of walk through a
minute and the app of both done very
well and they're growing quickly and
they've won awards and we've got a great
audience and that's growing but it's
we're competing on the one hand in a
world that moves relatively slowly I say
competing i don't really competing i
mean kind of operating within a world
within a world because our approach is
definitely not i'm trying to you know
compete really asst it's obvious trying
to find a place for history pin and but
it's about trying to add value and
through you know our approach to add
value to other people's work so within
with the kind of academic world in the
institutional weldon archive world we're
moving very quickly and we've had
enormous support and growth within the
area within the kind of tech world where
these projects have enormous tech
development budgets we kind of have to
scramble a bit more to keep up so these
tools are good but probably a year on
we've had to work much harder than we
thought to update them kind of every
month and and to find the budgets to do
that has been quite challenging but
we'll talk a bit more about how the
project sustained at the end and but
essentially the tools are based around a
giant map onto which you can add images
video content and audio content and then
attached to those pieces of content
recollections and stories and then that
allows people to come back and
particular particular location in
particular dates and to explore that and
as the archive builds as the project
bills obviously this experience becomes
more and more immersive and so yes so
you you find yourself a piece of content
here I don't think you'll see you know
people the first person can have a bit
of story content and then lots of other
people can add further narrative to that
story content you've got the basic data
attached to it
then a more sophisticated data
particularly relevant for archives
libraries museums and then if that that
image is taken externally then it can be
overlaid on the street view and allow
this really lovely window into history
which again when we went back to the 16
year old boy test after develop the
tools this was this was scoring really
really highly because it suddenly allows
you to walk around your neighborhood in
a whole different way and open up these
windows into history and and often show
you know sometimes show that things look
very different but also show kind of in
lots of ways at life and if you know
sometimes but similar sometimes look
different but it ultimately feel closer
to history than you would so yeah this
this idea of making comparisons between
then and now is a core visual element of
the project and and obviously hit street
view is one way of doing that but
because she doesn't go everywhere well
not yet anyway and we what the new
smartphone app allows you to do is take
something called history pin repeat
which is allowing you to take a modern
replica of old picture so this is this
is John boss our San Francisco lead this
is his grandfather by the jefferson
world in 1950 and he went and stood next
to his grandfather and snapped history
can repeat allowing that comparison to
be made so that allows that idea of kind
of modern historic visual comparisons to
be taken everywhere inside outside
public spaces private spaces and and yes
or they said as well as image content
also at the moment in video and audio
content that's kind of gradually
evolving in there's more documents and
maps and all sorts of things coming on
this little man in Italy I shouldn't
think that he would have been talking
about spoken about all over the world
but he has done and and again you know
it starts to show that with with lots of
very rich diverse pieces of content you
can genuinely immerse yourself in a
moment through these tools and through
this technology and so and then I'm
audio content which is proving really
popular I don't think we're gonna be
here able to hear this fantastically
well and but what audio contents done is
is what which is probably growing much
quicker than we thought is allow people
to recreate
kind of events and concerts in a really
compelling way so this is Neville
Chamberlain announcement that beginning
the Second World War and people have
done things like I've recreate famous
concerts and with with images and audio
files and videos and that kind of thing
so that's the the core site tools out
they stand there were lots of other
features which are water a little bit
and the smartphone application this is
actually the upgrade that comes out next
week but that the kind of core
experience of that is still this idea of
wandering around a map and finding
content near to you and and then by
pulling up that content and reading
stories and and then using your camera
view to be able to wander round and see
images near you so this is what happens
if you hold up the camera view outside
our office in London you see there's a
whole load of images near you and then
you find one that's close by so this
one's 177 metres away it's Smithfield
market you walk down Smithfield market
and then you can then overlay the the
old image on top of the new image which
yesterday I did all the way down there
this is a really wonderful collection of
content over side of the park of a whole
series of old buildings on on fifth and
Anna so really it's a really kind of
magic experience when the collections
are really which further this is just
outside and some Paul's a little bit
particularly well we're just showing how
and actually histamine simples is about
exams in some ways it looks exactly the
same as it did 80 years ago but you can
overlay a black and white image of the
same view but there are there are people
and things going on that picture but
essentially I mean again this is proved
really the app has grown particularly
quickly it's got about five hundred
fifty thousand downloads and will I
think become an increasing way for
people to digitize content at their own
collections as well so people taking a
picture of an old picture rather than
going through a kind of formal scanning
process is becoming more and more
prevalent as well so in terms of people
exploring and adding content the app is
a particular important part of the
object and then what we do which is
which again what I did down for seven
years today and is we invite people to
take a modern replica of that old
picture which again does to really nice
things for the system one it gives it it
gives the system another comparison to
make and it also gives you an exact bit
of geolocation data relating to the
footprint of the of the original
photographer if the person today stood
in the same place so the other site in
the app are the core digital tools and
then the the world of history pin in
terms of how we approach the project and
how we develop it is divided at the
moment into three main areas where
because of relationships like this and
because of a relationship that we've
just about to kick off formally with
Stanford in in California and with
King's College in London universities
and our education will become a kind of
fourth pillar of this and but at the
moment we divide up our audiences into
citizen historians which is what we call
our everyday users and it's about 55,000
registered users on history payment
about there's a safe flight of over half
a million app download users and
libraries archives museums and with is
around around 350 contributing around
the world that's probably one area
that's grown particularly quickly I
think lots of libraries archives museums
were waiting for a project that was
non-commercial and that didn't take any
copyright and that had the kind of aims
and ambitions that we've had and and so
that audience has grown really really
fast and probably about sixty percent of
those who in the u.s. about thirty
percent in the UK and then about ten
percent in around the world there may be
more at twenty percent around the rest
of the world and Australia's growing
very quickly in that sets as well and
then local community work and I think
probably which I'll talk a bit more
about the project is add its best when
it's trying to I mean because of our
route we're able to recognize that lots
of the things that Silicon Valley does
around content like this and needs what
I will always miss what goes on in local
communities around cultural heritage and
that most of our metadata crowdsourcing
which is what kind of our new set of
tools is all about which is the idea of
finding the dates and the locate
and the tags attached a particular piece
of content most of that is offline and
sitting around tables with groups of
people with cups of tea in pieces of
paper and the tools come into it you
know so they'll be one person around
that table who then gets all that mess
today to onto the system but most of the
metadata crowdsourcing despite how
technical it sounds is just about
conversations with people in communities
and so that overlap between online and
offline presence is particularly with it
if there's a Venn diagram of online and
offline in a long line and offline local
archiving and communal storytelling we
definitely see ourselves in that bit in
the middle so suited historians I mean
essentially the the core tools of the
project are designed to appeal to a
mainstream audience and they divide up
for us into six areas so obviously the
main map which we've had a look at the
street view overlays the storytelling
and and you know this idea of if you
don't have content to necessarily pin
you or where people always going to have
memories and and recollections so that
chemical storytelling again is growing
really nicely around you know particular
areas of content in particular and
collections which is where content can
be cool there is a particular yeah a
particular favorite theme running
through our office at the moment and I
think collections and which allows
content to be grouped together and then
tours which allow content to be strung
together into a narrative start together
in a particular order tours it's
probably proved the most popular part of
kind of means of curation of content and
this idea of I'm actually particularly
environments like like schools and
obviously people to do walking tours and
things and people being able to kind of
piece together a whole series of pins
into a into a journey and they'll allow
people to explore that journey either
online or with the app it's a kind of
free free tool maker that is yeah
proving really popular and really
effective and then the history pin
repeat which I said it has been launched
which is this really nice way of kind of
adding further
comparisons between old images and their
modern comparisons um so and those core
tools in relation to that mainstream
audience will continue to grow and
they'll always be very very simple and
and ideally eye-catching and and based
on that idea that 99% of this audience
I'm just going to come and look and one
percent of the audience are going to
contribute an ad something which is
fairly standard well we're at about two
and a half percent now but as the
audience grows it'll tend to go down to
that kind of one percent rule which is
fairly standard for projects like this
and for libraries archives museums and
the the tools get a little bit more
sophisticated and the one of the main
pieces of new development we've had for
this audience has been our channels
which which everyone can use but
essentially it's it it's a section of
the site which can be defined and
skinned purely for that particular
institution so it can be branded in a
design it just shows their content and
essentially and also shows any stories
that have been added to that content and
any repeats that have been done in
relation to that content so what what
what a channel does is essentially give
an institution their own space their own
home on history pin which can then be
curated obviously all that all the
content will go on the main map as well
but this is a kind of a space that
allows them to kind of show off their
collections in isolation and they've
proved really really popular only
launched it about eight weeks ago and
all these do and you know this is pretty
about fifty percent of all users took
them up very quickly and started
designing them and the rest are coming
on slowly so am and the channels also
the channels essentially based around
this main central panel this is the
Imperial War Museum channel which allows
the replicates all the same content as
on the main history pin map but just in
relation to that users content so the
Imperial War Museum for example
obviously they liked seeing their
content mixed up with everyone else's
but they've particularly been drawn to
this idea of showing what is really kind
of very striking content in isolation on
the map and they can control that
environment
as as much as they need to and and then
also yes stories in relation to those
content can be looked at so within this
one a particular event anti-vietnam
processed in protest in 1968 in
Grosvenor Square in London and a whole
series and people have added more
stories to that and then also in this
particular archive has been quite
popular for repeats so they can go and
see who's gone and taken some modern
replicas of their they're all pictures
and so yeah the channels functionality
is particularly aimed at the the
archival community and and one of the
things that goes along with that is
embeds so this is someone that has
skipped the m2 second story so this is a
bath in time and that he's and they've
embedded history pin on their own
website so essentially what the channel
allows you to do is grab code take that
code and stick on your own website and
then basically have his stupid tools on
your site which is proved really popular
more popular than we thought it's very
simple the way it works and it basically
allows people to have mapping tools on
their site but they never would have
been able to invest in themselves and it
all runs from the channel so all the
content that's on the institution's
channel then flows onto this and yeah I
mean it's it's because because all the
maintenance and all the moderation is
done on history pin it gives a kind of
very simple quick upgrade of tools to a
whole series of institutions then this
is a relatively small local archive in
the UK there never would have been able
to afford these kind of tools and now
they can have them on their on their on
their own site which has proved a real a
real boost for lots of institutions and
it also shows their collections and any
tools that they've made and and then
what goes along with these new tools is
the bulk uploader so this is the
powerhouse museums channel Australia and
they've designed it all up and this is
showing them using the bulk uploader
tool which allows so previously
each piece of content would be added one
by one this allows a whole batch of
files to be added alongside a CSV file a
spreadsheet with all of the metadata
related to that you'll see down the left
hand side there's a unique identifier
for each of those piece of content the
CSV files dropped in all the files are
dropped in and a few and around the
thousand i think at once can be added is
that will grow but it essentially a very
simple way of adding lots of content at
the moment there's no we don't have
api's to allow this to become automated
as such but it's suiting institutions to
be able to generate a CSV file from
their own database and then grab a whole
load of content and then put the two
together on history pin and they
integrate and then they all become
mapped according to the metadata if
there is no location or date information
within the spreadsheets then that
content appears on the channel but
doesn't appear on the main map so it'll
appear in the list view and then
institutions can go back through an ad
date or location or other information as
they find out more about it and that and
then they can pull back down an updated
spreadsheet from our system to update
their own systems with it'll be
gradually become more sophisticated and
more automated I think one of our people
are bit of reluctance at the moment is
that lots of institutions and archives
libraries museums universities have very
different systems there's around 40
systems that are used and and we want to
have the kind of lowest batha
participation at the moment we will
allow kind of more and more API and more
and more integration to happen
automatically and so yeah the bulk up
that at all is really the the number of
within kind of nine weeks the content
doubled pretty quickly on the back of
this partly because the channels were
such a big incentive for institutions to
get on test Japan and partly the bulk up
were allowed lots lots more to be shared
roughly as around kind of 150,000 pieces
of content on there around fifty percent
of that is from archives libraries
museums and around fifty percent of
those from everyday users which is
exactly the kind of balance that we were
looking to get that interaction between
formal collections and informal
collections or pro personal I mean
public and private collections is a
really big part
the project and and then these all of
these tools are complemented by a
history pen in residence program which
is where we get people out spending time
from our team within different
institutions we're aiming to have
someone on the ground in New York to be
able to spend time with lots of
different institutions fairly soon
hopefully it really really helps move
things forward and particularly because
we're such a young project and people
are just getting to know us that
face-to-face time makes a big difference
when it comes to developing ways to
collaborate and and then there's also
access to a whole series of helpdesk
tools and facilities and all that kind
of stuff so that is where where the
project stands at the moment in relation
to libraries our community aims and
obviously these three sections overlap
in lots and lots of ways and I think
what as I said this area the project
around local communities and how that I
mean one motivation of institutions are
lively darker museums participating it's
obviously to get to share their content
and interesting ways to open it up to
the public to increase access to allow
people to contribute to it but another
way is is as a as a means of local
community engagement so what we'd love
to be doing in New York over the next
year is to be designing a whole series
of projects across New York around
particular collection to a particular
ambitions and I'll speak a bit more
about how we design those projects but
essentially that that allows this
activity to happen and as I described at
the beginning that process of natural
mutually compelling intergenerational
storytelling is a big big part of the
project and flows out naturally from the
process of trying to gather and pin
content and and and the way that that
can then feed exhibitions and community
activities it's a natural it's a natural
force for Digital Inclusion and I don't
actually know what the digital exclusion
numbers here are in the UK there's about
eight million people that aren't online
and around 20 more million people that
use internet so irregularly that they
don't really count as being online and
that those rates are relatively low i'm
sure it's higher here but that is
creating a kind
and even bigger inter generational
divide and an intercultural and kind of
socio-economic divide as well so and a
lot of the reasons for that are a kind
of refusing it culture that the internet
isn't for me because it's kind of you
know passed you by and history pin is
hopefully a way of undermining a bit of
that reticence to get involved with the
internet within communities particularly
a means of training and skills I mean to
to to this is basically for us what a
metadata crowdsourcing session looks
like which is is just people coming
together and and often learning new
skills and certainly getting new
relationships and then within schools
the idea of being a teaching tool and a
community engagement tool for schools is
a schools are such a powerful hub of
these activities they've got all the
remit all the facilities all of the all
the incentives and to to get out into
their communities or invite people into
their schools and start gathering and
enriching local local archives local
heritage em so those are the three areas
of the project as it stands and I'm just
covering for time right and before I go
into 2012 and 2013 plans has anybody got
any anything they wanted to ask about
the kind of project as it stands yes yes
sure so flickr a flick flick flick or a
PR is a really important next step and
there's one in development so that
people want to people have got their
stuff onto flickr they can go straight
on a history pin and want in and it's
fairly easy we've done that flickr
sharing work and lots of so the yeah the
US National Archives a good example and
lots of others they've done that work
and there now they've started to use
history pin and getting content are
there it makes it relatively easy the
one bit and obviously our system needs a
flick a dozen is a bit more metadata
around date and location so often it's a
question of identifying things that have
been shared that have got that metadata
and they can be just drawn not straight
over but essentially the files and the
data is in shape to be able to migrate
it but yeah and you know we love liquor
as a great inspiration to us and we want
to make it as easy as possible for
people to participate in as many
projects as possible yes
yes well only because to begin with so
there's a simple answer nor longer
answer but there's the the simple answer
is that's when photography began and the
car and the site is currently made up of
images video and audio there is a we're
very close to extending that which will
do probably over the next few weeks
because there's more types of content
coming onto the site that are relevant
to the you know before that and the one
of the reasons why we started off with
recorded content is because we wanted to
create a line between subjective and
objective and that a pin would represent
recorded history that you couldn't just
make up and you could add subjective
things to that so people could interpret
and and and kind of gather narrative
around those recordings but essentially
I just couldn't stick on a pin on the
map saying this happened here obviously
photography and those recordings are
subjective in their own right and in
terms of certainly in terms of what
isn't recorded is enormously subjective
and but it felt like it was it was with
lots of other different kinds of
documents there was slightly with
slightly more of a gray area but we're
taking their gray error on now and then
in terms of there being documents and
illustrations and maps and a whole
series of different materials that run
before 18 40 barrels all start to come
onto the project very quickly yes yes so
there's about 16 of us a well across the
whole of we are we do the kind of parent
organization is about 20 of us in London
and San Francisco and Sydney most of
them in London and then if fired five on
top of that developers in Sofia and
Bulgaria and then probably about half of
that team are working on history bin so
there's probably about 12 people around
the world working full time on hitch pin
and then a network of lots of partners
and people and that that's made up of
digital creative communications a
content management team and and then
and then in terms of funding there's
there really is a long after that one
but I will do the short version which is
that we are partly funded by we're kind
of funded in a very traditional way and
then in an entrepreneurial way so the
traditional ways and grants from
foundations and trusts and particularly
with such strong social objectives and
such kind of strong educational work we
do get quite a good flow of grants and
support from foundations and trusts and
and that probably constitutes about kind
of between 50 and 60 percent of the
funding and then on the kind of service
and product side we on the platform
itself we as I said we weren't charged
wrap downloads we won't charge for
access we don't use advertising mainly
because the content isn't ours and we
recognize that we don't have monetize
the content but the tools our are ours
and we can monetize those in separate
environments so for example we just
signed a deal with a big TV station here
to embed our tools in their back-end to
be their kind of user generated content
system which with totally separate from
history pinner and without to kind of
take a margin from that and reinvest it
in the project and then we will also do
things like there's already been a
demand for you know more and more of the
kind of services we provide to add value
to all of this so special interface
design for particular projects or
partnerships the history pinion resident
stuff is kind of funded and then and we
may also consider depending on how the
community feel about it things like a
kind of channel plus feature or
something like that so you have a
standard channel and then if you want a
whole lot of customization features you
as an institution you pay a subscription
or something like that but the idea is
to keep the commercial bits as far away
as possible from the mainstream
experience it's only doesn't affect it
in any way but it's yeah an ongoing
challenge and as I said the hardest bit
is we need we really need half a million
dollars year of Digital development
that's our kind of that's what we should
be spending we're spending about third
of that at the moment which is where
Bulgaria comes in handy
but and to get that bit is most hard
because the grants and the trust
foundations find it hardest to fund a
digital development team they love
funding the community engagement the
educational work but and the you know
kind of cultural heritage work
specifically so but yeah it's an ongoing
puzzle that we're working out as we go
and it's a bit of an experiment to how
you run something like this without
commercializing it and which we never
will but it's a for it to meet them Ames
that we wanted and ambitions we want it
to reach its going to need a huge amount
of money and how to get that is an
ongoing awesome anything else before I
move on yes what about donations yes so
we've got it we've got a here we've got
a with just in the u.s. setting up ur
ourselves as a 501c3 to be able to
accept donations that's already in place
in the UK so in the UK we do accept some
so and I think there's probably some
interesting ways of doing that the
there's a basic if you like is to pin
help us out and then there's perhaps
donations in relation to particular
projects or collections so if you want
to support us going into this community
or working with this institution or you
know supports doing that so and as I'll
talk about with the project's model as
history pin divides up into a series of
tasks so the idea of contributing to a
huge map through time is nice but
difficult where were specific tasks as
I've explainable detail it is much more
manageable and those tasks could be kind
of crowd funded I think as well ok so in
2012 and 2013 and we've got two main
pieces of the development going on one
is around metadata crowdsourcing tools
which is something we're specifically
working with with Stanford on but will
collaborate with a whole series of
different organizations but the spatial
history lab over there is been doing all
sorts of really interesting data related
mapping stuff and that's overlapped a
lot with our work so we've been doing
some joint applications for a tool
development so it's n chua Lee where
this starts is that this particular this
is a test interface alone but this
image for example boring as it looks it
is full of mysteries so we know it was
somewhere lat mr. high street we know
somewhere in the 1960s but apart from
that there were you know the specific
location the specific date what who's
getting out of the car what car is it
what all the shops are anything anything
else that helps explain the context of
this image there are probably 10
mysteries around this that could be
solved and that data doesn't exist in
relation to a piece of content and
therefore these tools will invite people
to solve collaborators to solve all
those mysteries which will be interview
know we've started doing lots of paper
testing of this which is basically
getting people round and trying to solve
those mysteries together or running
Google Hangouts across the world and
getting people solve this mystery
further the conversations and the
community kind of cohesion that we want
to generate its if just as valuable if
not more valuable than the actual hunt
for content in the first place so that's
the first bit let's get this stuff out
and digitized monta Streep in the second
bit of trying to complete our
understanding of that is another whole
series of conversations and pieces of
collaboration so as I said this is it
one of the test interfaces we're working
on on the right-hand side you'll see
that in this case we're testing location
date Street View position and caption as
areas that could be edited and agreed
upon and then a whole series of tags in
latter versions are also testing spatial
tags which is where particular bits of
the content is tagged also with video
we're testing a dynamic spatial tags
which is where the pin can essentially
follow the footage through place and
time so you can show how it how it moves
through and and the idea being that
people make an edit on one of those
areas they justify that edit and then
the way we'll build a system of them to
begin with is the content owner will be
able to sign off that edit so there'll
be a say yes I agree that this photo was
in 1962 tick and then someone else will
say Ashley I think it was the 12th of
August nineteen sixty two minutes of
debate and then the owner will take that
and gradually the content will give data
will get more and more
cure it gets complicated it's already
proving very complicated because some of
the things that easy to agree so around
something like a street view overlay
it's obvious when it's right around lots
of other piece of metadata it may never
be obvious exactly what what's right and
it may be impossible to find a right
answer so what the crowd can agree upon
via this kind of process is an
interesting thing to test and develop
and but that technical development is a
very big part than work in the next 12
months and the idea being that and
people can arrive with collections which
they know very little about they can put
those into an interface and allow the
crowd to get stuck into them and then
come out the other end with a collection
they know an enormous amount about and
in the meantime there's been lots of
community engagement they've been lots
of conversations and it becomes more
useful academically institutionally in
terms of exhibitions and publishing and
there have been lots of really
interesting crowdsourcing projects going
on and they tend to be most intend to be
transcription crowdsourcing projects
which are really nice but I think we're
particularly interested in in
crowdsourcing that you can't do on your
own then you have to talk to people
about or you have to research or you
know get involved in some kind of
discussion that photo of my ground at
the beginning there's only two people
alive now that know the story behind
that and therefore there's a kind of
there has to be a mass to this kind of
crowd sourcing it's not something that
just a few people can do you know in
libraries or basements it has to be a
community conversation so yeah this is
this is a piece of technology called
technological development it's also
about how we pull in expertise from lots
of environments that aren't digital and
when you go into community settings then
they've got one old pc that doesn't work
and no internet connection and it's not
about this kind of tools it's about it's
about how we funnel and channel the
conversations into a green metadata the
second part is project-based
crowdsourcing so this is probably when
we launch this your PIN we were very oh
learn about what the project obviously
within parameters we were quite open
about what the project will become and
how the community would use it and
what's become obvious is that project
based or task based or challenge based
yusuff piston pin is is very popular and
growing all the time and what I mean by
that is something that has particular
kind of criteria for participation
defined so we are going to set out to
tell the history of this particular this
particular campus over the last 100
years and that's our parameters and
we're going to set up and run that
project with particular communities it's
going to have a it's going to have a
start it's going to have an end I mean
obviously these projects don't often
have an end because you can never
uncover all the history of the campus
but but you kind of design it in a way
that gives it some focus and some
purpose and some some parameters and or
it could be yeah we're going to tell the
history of this particular street corner
or this person or when we have the
message crowdsourcing tools the
challenge might be these are ten
thousand images we know nothing about
let's find out as much as we can about
over the next six months we just did a
really nice test with Brooklyn Museum
they had 500 pieces of content that they
had no geolocation data fall and they
put them at the community and said let's
pin all of these pieces of content and
by the end of it within about three
weeks they had all the location data for
all these pieces of content and so
challenges and tasks is what will
undoubtedly dominate history pin within
probably about six to nine months and
when you come to history pin you will of
course always find the big map through
time but actually you're more likely to
find a world of small groups of people
working on particular tasks and those
tasks aggregating and cross pollinating
in lots of interesting ways so to walk
through I mean and what's the idea of
the next 12 months in New York is to
work in partnership with a series of
different partners arm as we develop
these the kind of open source tools on
five or six projects and that we get
some people get someone on the ground
here that can support that and we define
them together and kind of support them
and managed activities together so these
yeah these challenges could have
particular aims and targets so this is
the Fleischmann bakery down was on the
corner of eleventh and something else
Broadway movie and a famous building
with a really rich history to it that
now is something completely different an
example of a challenge could be to find
out as much as possible about this
building and what that immediately does
which is really nice and we found again
and again is it it immediately rates and
makes that activity relevant to a
particular community so one of the
projects we've done on a council estate
in North London and which now doesn't
exist but it was these huge old
buildings that were taken down and
thousands of people know somebody that
lived in those buildings or has a story
attached to those buildings and it a
community of interest immediately
develops around that particular project
so I think what's nice about the project
model or these cysts and history
challenges we call them is that they
they bring together a particular group
of people with a particular interest and
ambition so yeah the theme when the
subject is defined the audience and the
participants naturally define themselves
and then the activities and events do as
well so and I'll talk a bit more about
one project we've done in in real depth
but essentially the community became
filled with events and activities and
meetups and hangouts of people trying to
break down bits of the bits of the
challenge in hand so once this challenge
is being established and then there is
there it has I mean and this is kind of
talking about what worked for us but it
won't necessarily define all projects
the role for champions has been
particularly important people who take
this challenge up and and promote it and
further it and I get really involved in
it and a big role for obviously cultural
heritage institutions sometimes one but
actually normally around any particular
area or era or subject there are a whole
series of different archives that are
going to be able to contribute in some
way so with the one I'll talk through
more about there were nine heritage
institutions and archives that also
contributed to it and community groups
community organizations again this is
whether they're kind of the you get the
really nice
you know intergenerational and community
storytelling coming out around these
challenges with and the interaction I
think traditionally library barcode
museums and may I say at universities
are not sure are not fantastic engaging
their communities but these these kind
of projects are a way to do that is if
you're working together on the history
of a particular area so yeah as one of
the projects we so within this reading
project which I'll talk more about
reading university got very heavily
involved within the kind of East Palo
Alto project we've been developing
Stanford have got heavily involved and
it's a it's really good for the
University and for the students to be
collaborating on something rather than
just kind of I guess investigating
sniffing around so it though it's a
really it's proved a really nice way of
universities coming together with their
communities and institutions as well and
schools within these projects play a
very important role and and then have
added lots and lots of activity and
engagement to all of them and
universities I said are becoming more
and more important to all of our work
and the idea that which we found really
compelling that there is a obviously an
interest in the content that gets
gathered all the stories that come out
all the things that we find out about
collections or subjects there's also an
interest in the process itself how you
go from not only very much about
something via thousands of people to
knowing a lot about things is a
fascinating process to examine in itself
so and then there so we you know there
was our role within this which is
designed particularly interfaces this is
an example of a challenge that we ran
for the last couple of months as you
will have seen we are all royal mad at
the moment and we did a challenge to
invite people to pin the Queen's history
over the last sixty years and it was
really it was really lovely the stuff
that came and everyone gets their camera
out the Queen comes to visit and we
developed a particular interface for it
to give it some distinctiveness and put
lots of resource on it and then lots and
lots of activities and events so having
developed the chair
having developed a network of people
bought into that challenge then then
getting it moving with lots and lots of
activities and the number of the number
of things you can do around around
active around challenges like this a
kind of endless them and publishing so
once this content has been gathered or
while it's being gathered for it to be
published in different places is really
important this is an example of
something we were doing with the San
Francisco Metropolitan Transport archive
where a lot of the content that got
gathered through a project we are
working on got overlaid onto bus
shelters so you can look through the bus
shelter at the modern thing behind it so
that building which you can't see very
well is behind the bus shelter and so it
creates that overlay effect which is
really nice and there's low what what I
mean again this it can be books it can
be exhibitions it can be projections
there's lots of ways of bringing this
content back out once it's been gathered
and and now we're just scratching the
surface of this i think the
possibilities for what communities can
achieve when they come together around
particular citizen history tasks and
then what they can take back out is is
really exciting and will go a lot of
interesting places we're not expecting
and so i will now yeah so and then
obviously out of all of that we're
particularly interested in defining and
measuring a lot of the social outcomes
working with institutions they'll be
particular in the culture of hashtag our
outcomes working with with academic
teams and universities they'll be
interested in some of the kind of
research conclusions but these ones are
the kind of things that we measure
within these projects and so to walk you
through an example of one of these
projects and reading which which is very
difficult not to pronounce reading if
you're American but reading into town
just outside London which we picked for
our pilot project at the end of last
year partly because it's regarded as
quite a boring place but actually where
you kind of change train but actually
when you scratch the surface it sort of
very rich history to it and it was
famous for the 3 b's which was beer
biscuits and
bulbs but and while we were running this
project actually the final be closed
down so the final brewery closed down
and was replaced by reading 12th Tesco
supermarket so and then yourself became
a fascinating story so I mean but and
and a kind of allow people to engage
with the history in different ways so to
walk you through this project we spent
around the court five months preparing
and then we had a three months public
engagement phase during that public
engagement phase we aim to create
communal archive of 200 years of reading
history this is quite a big challenge
actually and we found that it broke
itself down into lots of much smaller
challenges as we'll talk a bit more
about and we involve 32 community groups
and organizations we 35 schools took
part all the schools pretty much it was
it was about 80 volunteers and champions
played a particularly important role
during this time 2000s under 2,000
people participated Roger buted within
three months reading museum as part of
it routing ran an exhibition to which
17,000 people came to and it proved so
popular that they ended up committing a
kind of permanent space to it because
obviously the selectivity doesn't stop
at the end of a delivery period it
continues in evolves and perpetuates and
the round during the three months around
hundred twenty-five thousand people came
and and visited the content online and
and then from all of that during those
three months around just over four
thousand pieces of content were gathered
and then since the project ended in
December around a lot of three thousand
have continued to be added so what's so
exciting for us is that this activity
stuck within the community and continued
and group and then measuring all of this
really closely as we did we got we
always get external evaluators to come
and look at the impact of our work the
effects are learning more about local
heritage is one area we wanted to
examine came out really strongly I think
if it hadn't come out strongly would
have been surprised because this
obviously the project was about local
heritage but the diversity of appeal of
local heritage which is really was
really impressive and effect on ppl
census community
and sixty percent feeling close to their
community result of participating was
really strong we were really pleased
with that and people just that kind of
shared sense of place that people are
often missing were they move in and out
of communities quickly or when they just
don't develop a relationship with their
neighbors that sense of place was
something we wanted to measure closely
and came out strongly and interesting
the regularity so in that quote on the
bottom left hand corner and coming here
every Friday and interacting with the
broader range of people has been useful
looking a bit more about differed as a
software so that first point coming in
every Friday the regularity of it was
really important and ultimately we kind
of yes project by project but we want it
to be a become a permanent activity and
yeah the kind of role of regularity
within community activities came out
recently and effects on relations in a
generation this was really strong and
and and we've seen this in all the
projects we've run that it's just a
natural force we never talk about it as
an intergenerational project and we
never say the young person dear old
person please come and talk about
history we just put on activities that
are appealing to both groups and out of
it comes quite often I mean it isn't set
like this but quite often the younger
people are playing the role of kind of
digital activists and doing a lot of the
digitization and pinning and the other
people that become the kind of
gatekeepers to local memory and are very
valued within that role and the two
combined into into a really nice set of
social outcomes and then finally
probably our most important stats about
forty percent of participants became
more involved in activities in their
community since taking part in the
project which was which we was higher
than we were expecting so having people
having come to a few you know community
archiving projects then when out via
those connections and that community
confidence and became involved in a lot
more when they in their community which
we were really pleased about and so we
yeah so this is an example of a project
that was it was quite well funded and it
was very heavily evaluated but our aim
is now to to run
you know in New York in particular to
run a whole series of these projects and
while we're doing it to develop the
tools that allow anybody to set them up
on the site at the moment we set up
projects and challenges and we manage
them and curate them and work with
partners to do that but by the early
next year the idea is that anybody can
come and set up and run a project of
their own shooting and so yeah so so one
of the aims of obviously this visit and
this particular torque is to you know
tell you more about is beeping how to
contribute and how to get collections on
there and one of it is to get people
thinking about how we might work
together on particular project a project
I'm you know probably at its best when
there is a I mean I would you know
something like university campuses
actually got a good example or
particular neighborhood and because it's
often quite a lot of archival
collections connected to it there's
people there's a lot of people who have
got a kind of a buy into that those
memories and a part of those memories
and yeah so so we just to give you an
example of one that we're really
gathered here there is a kind of budding
Queens memory project Queens which I
haven't been to before which is as
diverse places I'd ever visited and and
and an amazing that kind of we've been
looking at how the tools can reflect
different layers of migration and and
the impact of that migration on all kind
of local culture and queens seems to
kind of you know replace itself its
communities very very quickly so that
map would look fascinating but yeah so
that's that's that's an example of one
and i think the aim really is to
accumulate a series of really good ideas
and good partners and then get back here
get some resource on the ground and
start working on things so yeah thank
you